what's the question it says find the
gradient and y intercept of the
following straight lines now they don't
ask us to draw this yeah but let's do it
anyway it's really really quick and
that's actually the important that's
where these questions are heading okay
so we're doing this question and the
equation or the rule they give us is y
equals minus 5x minus 48 okay now we're
being asked to find two things and then
using those two things we can draw this
ok we're looking for gradient and y
intercept now the greater and the wider
set let's just remember what they are
gradient gradient is about how steep a
line is alright so picture hill ok if
it's just kind of like a gentle hill up
he go it would have a gentle Lord
gradient right and if it was a steeper
Hill it would have a higher gradient
what if it was down here would have an
80 grand cuz it's dropping down right
it's about rise over run but you're not
rising you're going down ok so gradient
that's why another word for it is slow
ok so what the other thing we're looking
for is a y-intercept what does intercept
me interceptor line is it's whether it's
were they that they collide they hit
each other they intersect even it's a
very similar ok so it's where our graph
hits the y-axis ok where we hit the y
axis ok so that's what they are but what
are the values of the gradient and the
waves that you can just read them off
the equation right have a look yeah good
you can see this is minus 5 at the front
and that is the gradient hopefully this
is in your head for my lead we did
coordinate geometry ok if you can't
remember that know that can have a look
at the past lessons so that's minus 5
that's the gradient then you've got the
other number which is the wireless it
now be careful careful it's not eight
it's not a it's it's negative eight it's
got the negative in front on so you eat
negative 8 Georgia taxes ok did you
start drawing said axes yep you're ahead
of me then you probably this week i'll
actually not take that back i reckon to
be early next week yeah cuz then we have
one actually I what's all about though
it's all that lines ok here's my set of
axes now just as a point of interest you
probably do enjoy your set of axes like
this you probably drew it I mean I kind
of stand away of joy said vaccine is to
make it somewhat symmetrical like that
ok now i wonder if you can see why i
have drawn it like this because negative
ok so look at both these numbers I'm
sorry I sure yeah you should have went
but that's luckily you're right ok both
of these numbers are negative so that
means number one this y intercept it's
going to be all the way down well
negative 8 actually let's put that on
down ok so if I've got zero up here
that's the origin there's my y-axis
there's my x-axis so here is where the
y-axis is intersecting with the ground
so I'll just make that mindset there's
no reason to put minus ones with your
fine showing it you just need them on
its employ papi ok so then I just need
to draw my line it has a grain of minus
five so is that mean it means it's it's
it's dropping down it's decreasing its
not rising it's running from shopping I
guess ok um and it's a fine that's
really really steep right you just got
my
drop off like that so I'm going to draw
a line something like this super Steve
well ok now ok the next n logical
question is what's that value up there
now this question it doesn't ask us what
that is but you know what we can work it
out anywhere we can work out anywhere it
doesn't take more ok have a look at this
see how this point here is point hyung
it'll have an x coordinate and a
y-coordinate right just like every point
has every point has an X in the
y-coordinate right but you actually know
what the y-coordinate is even though I
just drawn it really roughly know that I
think carefully why is about up down up
down and this point is lined up with the
origin right so so everything along here
the Y value is zero it's on the axis ok
so you can say with confidence even if
you don't know anything else about it
that point its y-coordinate should be
zero ok because it's on the axis there
so therefore in order to find out well
ok what's what's the other number what's
the X corner you take this rule this
equation this sound this algebra stuff
right and you say well what happens if y
equals zero if y equals 0 what happens
to this thing well there's there's y
over there so i will substitute 0 for y
i get this 0 equals ok and then you need
to solve it now save you a bit of time I
can already see right now that the
solution to this is going to be minus
eight over five you can go ahead and do
the steps test it out if you like but
that's the day you're going to
eventually get so that that's the x
coordinate minus eight
fine okay so you're gonna have to solve
this together because have a look at
this right this is this is along here
this is the Atlantis writer everywhere
on the x axis the y coordinate should be
0 right because they haven't gone up you
haven't gone down your equal to this
like if you like you think about like
this this is kind of like I'm you know
sea level or something like that okay so
it's like I haven't gone up 10 kind of
em down or gone and into a summary like
that I'm just at sea level okay so
everywhere he should have a altitude I
guess 0 0 right so that's why I don't
know y coordinate is 0 oh hello you can
do that with any gradient and wine
dessert okay yes you can and that's
exactly what we're going to do on the
next question so have a look at 2g okay
finance that's it that's it that's the
final answer I mean what they wanted was
this and we also drew it often the art
the drawing the sketch is the actual
question okay